congratulations is that an appropriate
way to say it or do you tell me how do
you god no yeah that's that's
appropriate you know I think it's far
from over but no you know it was a good
good first step for sure well I mean how
long were you thinking in that moment um
I wasn't thinking about it that long
honestly you know I think it hit me
Monday morning when I woke up and and
that's kind of how I wanted to approach
how I wanted to push that whole day you
know I wanted to I wanted that whole day
to do your special as it could be
without you know making it more than
what it would might be or maybe not
having it be as special as it could have
been um so for whatever it was worth I
wanted to be exactly that and I didn't
want to read too much into it until it
got to that day well I mean were you
thinking about it I guess during
chemotherapy the fact that you were I
mean what were you fixing on to get
yourself through that experience Chad um
I wasn't thinking about baseball at all
to tell you the truth and be completely
honest with you of it was you know
winging more still on my faith in my
family and and my daughter that had just
been born I think he is there was more
of getting through each day and being
able to go home and see my family my
wife and my daughter how old is your
daughter she's four months now man
honestly Jedi how did you take the
diagnosis with a wife at home and a
newborn care I mean with a so I would
have diagnosis hit when I would imagine
I guess your wife was pregnant
Chad oh yeah yep yeah uh yeah it was fun
honestly you know there was a lot of
questions we had one of the more
important ones being was the chemo
therapy going to affect how I was going
to be able to be a father and you know
was I going to be able to be with my
wife in the hospital when she was giving
birth was I going to be able to hold my
daughter because of the chemo drug and
and so we had a lot of questions more
so on my expand my side from Christie
but no you know something that we have
to get this the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience isn't it
amazing you can download an app with
your thumbprint you should download our
app with your thumbprint